all right thank you so much thanks for
coming
my name is Roddick and the technical
director at nas B and in this
presentation I will show you how we've
built a truly cross-platform app sharing
the vast majority of our code between
not just iOS and Android but the web as
well without using react native web
react XP or other existing solutions the
following is a distillation of what
we've learned building those before our
company has had a successful product on
the market for 12 years but throughout
all of its iterations it has always been
a web app and three years ago we've
decided to rewrite everything from
scratch using react and react native
still being a small company it was
extremely important for us to share as
much code between all of the platforms
as possible so I'll show you a very
small snippet of the app just so you
have the context as to what sort of
challenges we face and overcome in our
quest to sharing code so nozbe is
essentially a to-do app for teams right
and this is filled with just randomly
generated data and notice a bunch of
mobile specific patterns here like the
drawer layout we have here now we have a
project and when I want to add a task
notice above the soft keyboard you have
a bar with attributes I can add to a
task in a task we have a discussion you
can see all the comments you can tap off
on reactions see who's reacted at a new
reaction and if you want to add a new
comment we'll have a full screen
interface for that and for above that
and all of the menus and Pickers will
have this bottom sheet card interface it
just makes a lot of sense on iOS it's
really nice to use with some tweaks on
Android as well now contrast that with
the desktop version which is also the
web version as you can see this is
mostly the same thing
mostly looks kind of the same works the
same way layout is completely different
though it's now not much bigger it's all
columns we don't have a soft keyboard so
the attributes are going to be on the
right of the input it doesn't make sense
to use a card interface so we use menus
and popovers also a lot of small tweaks
like everything is slightly smaller on
desktop we can use certain things like
hover gestures which are just not
available mobile and certain patterns
are just different for the web such as
if you want to add a new comment it
doesn't make sense to cover up the
entire screen it's better to have the
discussion in context right so as you
can see mostly the same thing mostly the
same UI logic product but a lot of
differences small and big so how do we
fare with code reuse how much code were
we able to reuse between all the
platforms as of last week maybe 2
percent and of course this is not just
like business logic theorem all
utilities it's pretty much all of the
the components as well so how do you do
that well one option is to go with one
of these libraries and this is sort of
an easy way to go like if you're
starting out you want something that's
been tested that a lot of other people
done this is the way to go if you have a
react native app that's already built
out and now you need to port it to the
web use react native web there's just
not much else to pick from but at least
for us when we start with two years ago
none of the solutions that existed fit
our bill we didn't think that it's the
right approach to take all of the react
native API and just bring it to the web
pretend that the web is react native we
wanted to chart a different path for
ourselves because we wanted to have
flexibility control over the
abstractions and really good performance
so instead of bringing react native to
the web we wanted to have as lightweight
as possible an abstraction layer that
bridges react native and the web instead
of bringing react native to the web so
we don't use any of that so how do we do
that instead
so let's start by talking just project
structure how do you go about having a
shared codebase we have everything in
one mono repo there's one repository for
the entire app and it comes in three
chunks one is the app folder and it
contains all of the application code all
of the application JavaScript the native
folder is for react native specific
things so react native configuration the
Xcode project the Android project all of
the negative Swift and Kotlin code we've
written and the web folder is mostly for
web pack configuration and things like
that we also have multiple package
Jason's the route one is purely for
development tools such as babel Aslan
chest app package jason is purely for
application dependencies that are shared
across the board native package Jason is
for react native specific tooling as
well as app dependencies that only work
for react native just to keep things
organized and the same for the web and
just like in react native you can have
dot IO SJS and Android JS files used to
configure all of our tools to accept web
page is and- that is when we have to
differentiate between those two
platforms so there's a lot of tools that
you need to make aware of this set up
that they understand the mono repo and
understand the custom file extensions so
unfortunately I won't go into the nuts
and bolts of how to configure that
because this could take the entire talk
but what we plan on doing is either to
write it up as a blog post or open
source a full project template later
this year okay so we have the mono repo
then we need kind of an infrastructure
layer the base building blocks upon
which we can build our app the most
important of which is of course react
and react native we have that but
there's an another piece that was really
important for us so hands up just sort
of curiosity how many of you know
watermelon to be alright
some people go so
here's the thing we need we needed some
sort of data persistence layer for the
app and the thing about nozbe it's an
offline first app so you have all of
your stuff downloaded offline on the
device and it's not uncommon to have
tens of thousands of records in the app
all the projects tasks and comments so
we need really good performance it needs
to be scalable the very common approach
of just going with you know persisting a
Redux or a Malbec store it just doesn't
work
trying to low load all of that at up
launch would slow things down
tremendously so we need a real database
we need everything to be lazy loaded but
because the app is really interactive we
also need it to be observable reactive
we need to be able to easily connect
datasource
to components so that they re render
when the data changed which is kind of
hard to combine with lazy loading it
needs to be capable of server
synchronization because it's not flying
first app and then you synchronize with
the server to get the same thing across
all devices and of course it needs to be
multi-platform it needs to understand
iOS Android and the web so nothing like
that existed and last year we open
sourced watermelon DB and you can check
it out online if that's relevant fair
project alright let's talk about styling
this is the first major obstacle to
sharing components between react native
and the web and you already know this
but just the API is completely different
here we have dips and spans on the web
we have capital V views and texts here
we have class names we have style it's
just the API difference is untenable we
can't use it like that we need an
abstraction layer so we really like the
approach of styled components not
necessarily the styled - component
library but a lot of libraries like that
because this abstracts away HTML and CSS
but at least when we started no such
library existed that would be both cross
platform between react native and the
web and be high-performance so we
created one and here's how it works
when you want to make a box or text you
import view or text from style that
abstracts away the difference between
view and div span and text and then you
import styles from a local file for the
component and you just define the style
component if you lose used something
like stealth components this is broadly
recognizable the box is a view its main
style is style that box if you want
conditional Styles you add that in if
you want to pass explicit as tells you
add that in and then in the render
method or the function component you
just use it like a normal component
right this way
we we neither directly used Dom nor do
we import react native and now this
Styles so ok here we do need two
different files unfortunately because of
the approach we took so we have styles
that native that j/s with just exports
as a stylesheet and a style web CSS with
the CSS classes and we use post CSS in
the web pack configuration such that the
CSS file is imported from JavaScript so
just import styles and it will import
the right thing depending on whether you
compiled for react native or the web
still even though we're duplicating that
part which is unfortunate and we do want
to share as much as possible so what we
do is we have a single style constants
file so we try not to ever use literals
in the Styles file like colors sizes
margins padding textiles instead we have
a standardized palette of all the colors
and sizes in one file and then you
either import that in native or you use
this CSS variables syntax which post CSS
compiles to the literal in this way this
is a good practice in general but
particularly when we do need those two
separate parts it's easier to just keep
things shared and in control so we were
thinking of opens
our styling style components library
since it's working pretty well for us
but we think we have an even better idea
see the problem is that our application
is big and complex enough that the
performance overhead of having like
actual components for each every each
and every box and and piece of text is
no longer negligible so we have a
project in the works which is codenamed
Zach's for Europe abstraction cost
styling that would still allow us to
have a completely shared abstraction for
building styled components but the
entire abstraction would be implemented
at compile level as a bubble plugin such
that the runtime cost of this is zero if
all goes well which you know we'll see
we'll open search that later this year
ok now let's talk about shared
components the first step is to build a
small library of very base UI components
and I just mean the sort of components
with whose implementation is completely
platform dependent so this is an almost
complete list that there's not as many
of those as you might think but
something like image text input icon for
vector icons or touchable which on the
web might be an anchor or a button or a
div on press you just have to make two
different implementations but there's
just a couple of them it's not a big
deal and now that we have those few
layers of abstraction the base UI
components library and a styling
approach making actual styled components
actual I'm sorry shared components is
trivial like there's not that much to
show you just build styled components
and you compose them together with the
base UI components library and this way
you neither have to import react native
or refer to Dom specific things in the
component in x rays file
it's that's really that's it in most
cases
of course the devil is in the details
and since we did not take the approach
of bringing react native to the web you
still have to deal with many platform
differences and you'll have to resolve
them so the first and simplest approach
is to just if else it and just like
react native has a platform export that
allows you to differentiate between iOS
and Android we have the same thing but
we also add is web and is native to the
mix in those cases that's really all
that's needed most differences are very
simple the second approach is to
abstract the differences using helpers
so for example when you have a text
input the events of those work slightly
differently on the web and in react
native on the web you might have
something like events target value on
react native events native events text
it's not a big deal you could if-else it
but it just becomes tiring when you have
to do it in 10 different places so
there's a lot of just really small
trivial differences like that and what
we do is you just make a simple helper
like this is essentially one line of
code with index web JS
index native Jas you encapsulate the
entire difference between those two
platforms and then in actual components
you don't see that difference you just
import a helper use that and all of the
component level code is the same the
third approach is what we call platform
files so imagine you have or imagine so
you have the route component of your app
right it probably has a lot of things
that are completely shared between all
the places you probably have some
context providers maybe some shared
logic but some things are obviously
different on the web you might have a
simple column based layout just like we
do and on react native you might be
using some sort of drawerlayout
react navigation what-have-you so you
don't want to duplicate all of the codes
since there are shared parts but also
you need to resolve those differences so
a common technique that we use is we
just have an index draya's file with
everything that's shared and the
differences are extracted into a
platform web GIS file and platform- JS
file
and then you just put all of the
snippets of components that are
different or low helper functions that
are just specific for this one component
and this approach is particularly useful
when you have to import dependencies
that only work on one of those two
platforms because if you put it in the
index.js file a lot of libraries a lot
of tools like babel web pack will just
get really confused by this
so in index in gs files you only import
things that are available everywhere in
that web GIS that Native Jes you import
things that are different and then you
can react sport it so that the index.js
file might use it and for the other
platform you just export a placeholder
such as a no op function or a component
that doesn't actually render anything
okay but sometimes it's not enough as a
last-ditch effort if you can't really
share it you might have to do two
different implementations
when will it be necessary one case is
when you have big platform differences
and again this is something like image
text input there's not a lot of those
the second reason to have two different
implementations is when you want to have
a completely different design for
example you saw in my screencast how we
have these menus and pictures that are
represent on all the platforms but are
represented visually differently such as
as a popover on the web and a bottom
sheet card on native so we have just one
component for it we call it model but it
has two different implementations that
implement a completely different design
the third reason to have this is when
you abstract over different dependencies
for instance we have a component called
list because pretty much all of our
lists are drag and drop a bomb and on
native you need something like flat list
for Liz virtualization to get good
performance so we don't want all of the
components all of the pages to have to
think about it and and know about these
differences so instead we have
components like lists with two different
implementations that wrap over two
different external libraries and
provide a common API for the rest of the
app it's important to note that even
when you do need two different
implementations you don't want to you
don't want to duplicate yourself if it's
not absolutely necessary so when you do
have parts that are shared extract them
like extract common logic to a hook or a
higher component and put it in a common
JS file that then you import from the
two different implementations or if you
have a really big complicated component
it should probably split it into smaller
parts and some of these might be
completely shared and really that's all
that's needed for 80 85 percent code
reuse still there are some missing
pieces we think we can do even better
and maybe get to 90 percent or more
without compromises by with just this
approach of having a shared lightweight
abstraction that shares across react
native and the web not bringing the
react native to the web for example
styling so my 82% figure okay I lied a
little bit doesn't include the styling
the styles that are a little bit
duplicated so react native web has a
solution of just compiling stylesheet to
CSS but we really didn't want to do that
and I don't think this is a lost cause I
think we can build a tool that will
provide an API that's as shared as
possible but just statically compiled
the styles for CSS and then for react
native I think we can do this performant
ly without compromises animations work
in a completely different way just
completely different sets of tools there
are many react animations libraries but
last time we did the research on that
most of them were frankly not very good
because they drove the animations from
JavaScript and it just won't get you
very nice smooth animations so actually
with we do have a partial solution it's
only for static animations it it won't
work when you need
something like react nested react native
gesture handler for interactive
animations but for static animations we
made a very small simple library that
essentially implements the react native
animated API but it's built on top of
web animations API so it actually has
really nice smooth 60fps animations
would anyone want to see that open
sourced nice it will think about it a
bundling two different bundlers that's
slightly annoying because those are like
pretty big complex pieces of
infrastructure that we just have to
maintain and we think the future is with
halt which is call stacks project to
bring web pack to or react native Alison
we checked it so had some missing pieces
but if not today then very soon I hope
we can completely share that and then
there's just a lot of small and big UI
components that you're just not gonna
implement yourself such as Liz
virtualization drag-and-drop navigation
and what-you-see-is-what-you-get editors
for like comments or something and in
all of these cases we had to use two
different implementations two different
third-party libraries and then make a
lightweight abstraction to bridge them
together for WYSIWYG WordPress recently
made the Guttenberg editor which might
be solution to this and for other items
on that list there's some work in that
direction like with react navigation but
for now we can't truly share that and
then last but not least end-to-end
testing lower levels of testing you can
pretty easily share but for end-to-end
testing we have two great but completely
different libraries Cypress and detox
will be great to build an open source a
common abstraction to bridge the two
together or maybe you start with a
completely different approach like use
kV and build that out to be like truly
fully featured they'll be great all
right now before I leave the stage I
want to share something with you a
controversial pin I think it's
controversial
so in the beginning when you wanted to
have a nap you build the app and if you
wanted to have an app for iOS and for
Android you build an iOS app an Android
app but what about if you want a web app
an iOS app an Android app a Mac OS app
in a Windows app they'll be great right
for something for an app like ours that
would be perfect but but then we've with
the the first the correct approach of
writing it everywhere now we have to
hire and build about five different
teams that will design the same app
implement the same app fix the same
issues over and over again this is
wasteful and really disheartening when
you build something that somebody
already built just against a slightly
different framework and it's really
expensive I mean think about it even big
companies like Twitter or slack can't
make native mac OS apps it's just too
much so someone came up with a great
idea let's just write it once and run it
everywhere right it's it's mm let's just
write everything in Java and ten years
later let's just write everything in
Java Script put it in a electron or
PhoneGap run it everywhere that's great
right no the problem here is it almost
inevitably leads to bad user experience
now each platform is unique and
different and users have different
expectations that needs to be respected
and so react native came up with this
great mantra learn one's right
everywhere now this is great I love this
the idea here is you only have to learn
the react paradigm once right in
JavaScript and then you can use this
knowledge to target the web and react
native it appreciates the needs to not
redo work that were only there are
technical different
but at the same time there are platform
differences as well they need to be
respected but is that enough I don't
think that's enough yes that's great
that we learn once right everywhere but
why do we have to write everywhere yes
there are UX differences that need to be
respected but a lot of differences
between react native and the web are
merely technical differences they're
just incidental complexity not real one
so I want to propose a new mantra for
the community the Galactic brain choice
right ones learn everywhere let me
explain let me explain here's the idea
if 90% of your app of its logic UI
layout is the same so should be the code
you shouldn't go for 100% code reuse you
should go for 90% code reuse each
platform needs to be respected
right but we shouldn't have to write the
same thing over and over again just
because of some technical differences
like isn't that just silly so I think we
should write once everything that is the
same but we shouldn't just be lazy and
like oh we've written once and now we
run it everywhere now we don't run it
every where now that we've saved time by
writing it once we can reinvest that
time to learn all of the platforms and I
think if we really want to step up our
game and make a really great user
experience we should learn all of the
platforms yes we want to share as much
code as possible but you should learn
DOM and CSS and HTML and UI kit Swift
Kotlin to make a truly great user
experience right so you write once
everything that is the same and then you
reinvest that to make a truly great app
for all of the platforms all right thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]